I'm on my way to Ines and I would have
to say that on a sort of excitement
scale I would count my wedding day birth
of my children and going to Ines house
it's an even playing field listen the
Barefoot Contessa has that effect on
some people Emily Blunt and lin-manuel
Miranda appear on an upcoming Mary
Poppins themed episode of Barefoot
Contessa cooked like a problem man you
heard Emily mention her family while
seeing Emily as the iconic nanny had
quite the effect on her husband John
Krasinski as Nancy O'Dell found out he
just cried and cried
he kept saying like what's happening to
me when he was watching it what scene
was it I got him so emotional well Ben
Whishaw song is so gorgeous when he's
talking about the loss of his wife yeah
I think he's sort of cried from then
onwards everything is possible even the
impossible as the revamp Mary Poppins
Emily's practically perfect in every way
but she admits taking on the role was a
daunting task for this mom of two did
you watch the original Mary Poppins with
you dawn so I watched it once I'd
wrapped our version of Mary Poppins
didn't want to watch it as an adult
before I played her because I kind of
knew I might be swayed by what Julie did
no one wants to see me do a cheap
impersonation of Judy hunters you know
this sequel to the classic has told 25
years after the original when the banks
children are all grown up for lin-manuel
Miranda bringing his son to set was a
career highlight I wanted him to see how
cool daddy's job was and and that's sort
of one of the moments I'll never forget
he got to see daddy doing that
eight-minute number in real time and his
eyes were like sort of saucers and that
was the best moment of the whole
experience
you have a little reunion with Brown
Street I know what was like watching her
transform into the crazy cousin touchy
she was I mean she's bonkers as Topsy
you know that's her actually swinging
around the chandeliers there's nobody
don't what are you doing you know she's
something chandeliers she she she she
can swing from the chandelier like SIA
great and now ladies if you can just
work on that Devil Wears Prada sequel I
will be one happy lady
[Music]
[Applause]